- Witaj z powrotem w kursie „Rozumienie
kwantowej informacji i obliczeń".
Nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym
ds. IBM Quantum Education.
To jest trzecia lekcja z serii. W pierwszych dwóch lekcjach mówiliśmy o podstawach
kwantowej informacji.
Najpierw dla pojedynczych układów w izolacji, a potem dla układów złożonych.
Omówiliśmy też pomiary
w standardowej bazie i operacje unitarne zarówno dla jednego, jak i
wielu układów.
W tej lekcji wprowadzimy
model quantum circuit, który daje nam standardowy sposób opisywania obliczeń kwantowych,
a możemy też używać quantum circuits do opisywania protokołów kwantowych i innych rodzajów interakcji obejmujących wiele urządzeń kwantowych.
Oprócz quantum circuits omówimy też kilka
ważnych pojęć matematycznych związanych z kwantową informacją,
i użyjemy ich, by zaobserwować
kilka fundamentalnych ograniczeń kwantowej informacji i tego, co możemy robić z quantum circuits.
To dobrze nas przygotuje na
następną lekcję, gdzie zobaczymy kilka
bardzo ważnych przykładów i zakończymy tym
pierwszą jednostkę serii
poświęconą podstawom kwantowej informacji.
Oto przegląd lekcji. Zaczniemy od modelu quantum circuit i zobaczymy, jak działa.
Następnie porozmawiamy o
niezwykle ważnym pojęciu iloczynu skalarnego, a także ortogonalności i rzutów,
które są związane z iloczynami skalarnymi. Nie omawialiśmy tych rzeczy
w pierwszych dwóch lekcjach, bo naprawdę nie
musieliśmy, ale teraz musimy.
Iloczyny skalarne dostarczają nam
narzędzia matematycznego, bez którego po prostu nie możemy się obejść.
Po prostu nie zajdziemy daleko w rozumieniu kwantowej informacji i
obliczeń bez iloczynów skalarnych.
W trzeciej części lekcji przyjrzymy się kilku
ważnym ograniczeniom kwantowej informacji.
Ostatecznie chcemy eksplorować ciekawe
rzeczy, które możemy robić z kwantową informacją, ale żeby robić to skutecznie,
musimy być świadomi pewnych
rzeczy, których nie możemy robić.
W szczególności omówimy
pojęcie globalnej fazy i to, dlaczego globalne fazy są nieistotne.
Zobaczymy sformułowanie
twierdzenia o nieklonowaniu, które mówi nam, że stanów kwantowych nie można w ogólności kopiować, i zobaczymy, że dwa stany kwantowe
nie mogą być doskonale
rozróżnione od siebie nawzajem, chyba że są ortogonalne — to fundamentalne
ograniczenie, o którym warto wiedzieć.
Pierwszym tematem lekcji
jest model quantum circuit, który jest modelem obliczeniowym
dającym nam sposób
opisywania obliczeń kwantowych.
Model quantum circuit opiera się
na bardziej ogólnym pojęciu w informatyce, jakim jest circuit, i można definiować wiele
różnych modeli obliczeniowych
na podstawie tego ogólnego pojęcia.
Podstawowa idea jest taka, że
circuit składa się z przewodów, które przenoszą informację, oraz gate'ów, które reprezentują operacje
stosowane do informacji
przenoszonej przez przewody.
Termin circuit to właściwie
dość dziwna nazwa dla tego rodzaju modelu,
bo słowo circuit
zazwyczaj odnosi się do
okrężnej ścieżki.
Ale kiedy mówimy o circuits
jako modelach obliczeniowych, zwykle mamy na myśli
acykliczne circuits
w których okrężne ścieżki nie są dozwolone.
Mówiąc dokładniej, na potrzeby
tej serii będziemy wymagać, aby
informacja zawsze płynęła od lewej do prawej w każdym circuit.
Więc jeśli wolisz, możesz
myśleć o circuits jako opisujących sekwencje operacji, gdzie czas płynie od lewej do prawej.
Oto przykład boolowskiego circuit, gdzie przewody przenoszą wartości binarne — zero lub jeden —
a gate'y reprezentują
operacje logiki boolowskiej.
Przewody są reprezentowane przez linie, a tutaj mamy dwa bity wejściowe oznaczone X i Y,
i jeśli chcemy wiedzieć,
co circuit robi dla konkretnego wyboru wejść, propagujemy wartości na
przewodach od lewej do prawej,
zależnie od działań,
które gate'y wykonują na wartościach przenoszonych przez przewody.
Na przykład możemy
sprawdzić, co się dzieje, gdy zaczynamy z górnym przewodem wejściowym ustawionym na wartość jeden, a dolnym przewodem wejściowym
ustawionym na wartość zero.
Te dwa przewody wejściowe prowadzą
do tych dwóch kropek tutaj, które reprezentują operacje fan-out, co oznacza, że wartość jest kopiowana,
dzięki czemu może być
przekazywana dalej wzdłuż wielu przewodów.
Jeśli to zrobimy, to te
dwa przewody przyjmują wartość jeden, taką samą jak to jeden tutaj, a te dwa przewody przyjmują wartość zero,
taką samą jak to zero tutaj.
Tutaj mamy gate NOT, który
jest oznaczony symbolem negacji logicznej, więc
wartość wychodzącą to zero,
co jest negacją logiczną jedynki. Podobnie wartość
wychodząca z tego gate'u to jeden, będący
negacją logiczną zera.
Te dwa gate'y to gate'y AND,
ten gate to gate OR, i jeśli kontynuujemy
i propagujemy wartości
WEBVTT
przez circuit, oceniając
gate'y odpowiednio, widzimy, że końcowa wartość
na tym przewodzie tutaj to jeden.
Cały circuit opisuje
sekwencję operacji złożonych tak jak sugeruje rysunek, i otrzymujemy funkcję
z dwóch bitów do jednego bitu
w tym konkretnym przypadku. Ale ogólnie może być dowolna liczba
wejściowych i wyjściowych bitów.
Ten konkretny circuit oblicza sumę modulo 2 (XOR) dwóch bitów wejściowych, więc wyjście to jeden
wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy dokładnie
jeden z dwóch bitów wejściowych jest ustawiony na jeden, a drugi na zero — ale to nie jest naprawdę
ważne, to tylko przykład.
Podstawowy fakt o boolowskich circuits jest taki, że każda funkcja z dowolnej liczby bitów do dowolnej liczby bitów może być obliczona
przez jakiś boolowski circuit, choć czasami może
być potrzebny bardzo duży circuit do obliczenia funkcji,
która cię interesuje.
Istnieją inne style
używane do opisywania circuits.
Na przykład ten rysunek
przedstawia dokładnie ten sam circuit co poprzednio, używając stylu być może bardziej typowego
w inżynierii elektrycznej, gdzie obowiązują konwencje dotyczące kształtów reprezentujących różne gate'y.
Nie będziemy używać
tego konkretnego stylu, ale wprowadzimy
własne symbole dla różnych quantum gate'ów, takich jak gate Hadamard,
gate Controlled NOT,
gate Toffoli i tak dalej.
Na marginesie, tutaj możemy zobaczyć pochodzenie
terminu circuit.
W kontekście inżynierii elektrycznej bardzo naturalne jest
myślenie o elektryczności krążącej przez circuit.
Ale w tej serii nie
mówimy o elektryczności przepływającej przez circuits — mówimy o informacji
przepływającej przez circuits.
I znowu dla nas będą one zawsze acykliczne, gdzie informacja
przemieszcza się od lewej do prawej.
Oto inny przykład
innego rodzaju circuit, zwanego circuit arytmetycznym.
Tym razem przewody przechowują liczby, a gate'y reprezentują
operacje arytmetyczne, takie jak dodawanie i mnożenie.
Tutaj możesz zobaczyć przykład
circuit arytmetycznego.
Nie jest ważne dla celów
tej lekcji, co on robi — to tylko przykład mający
przekazać ideę, że istnieją różne
pojęcia circuits.
Możemy też myśleć o
circuits obejmujących losowość, na przykład takich, gdzie gate'y reprezentują
operacje probabilistyczne, i jeśli chcesz,
możesz pewnie siedzieć cały dzień i wymyślać nowe modele obliczeniowe oparte na pojęciu circuits.
W modelu quantum circuit
przewody reprezentują qubity, a gate'y reprezentują zarówno operacje unitarne, jak i pomiary.
Oto bardzo prosty przykład
quantum circuit.
W tym circuit jest tylko jeden qubit, reprezentowany
przez poziomą linię, a gate'y zaznaczone kwadratami
reprezentują operacje unitarne wykonywane na tym qubicie.
Więc w tym konkretnym przykładzie nie ma pomiarów.
Jeśli chcemy nadać
qubitowi nazwę, na przykład X, możemy to zaznaczyć na diagramie, wpisując X tutaj — to jest opcjonalne.
Podobnie jak w przypadku boolowskiego circuit sprzed chwili, możemy myśleć o tym circuit
jako reprezentującym sekwencję operacji, gdzie czas
płynie od lewej do prawej.
Więc zaczynamy od X,
stosujemy pierwszy gate — gate Hadamard,
po którym następuje gate S,
potem kolejny gate
Hadamard, a na końcu gate T.
Widzieliśmy te operacje
pod koniec lekcji pierwszej i tutaj możesz zobaczyć
ich opisy macierzowe.
Kiedy wykonujemy te
cztery operacje po kolei, co oznacza najpierw H, potem
S, potem znowu H, a następnie T,
łączna operacja jest opisana
przez ten iloczyn tutaj, mając na uwadze, że kolejność
zasadniczo się odwraca,
jak omawialiśmy w lekcji pierwszej. Jeśli wykonamy mnożenie macierzy, otrzymamy tę macierz tutaj,
więc działanie circuit
na qubicie X jest opisane przez tę macierz unitarną.
Czasami chcemy wyraźnie zaznaczyć w diagramie quantum circuit,
jakie wejście podajemy, i możemy to zrobić tak jak widzisz tutaj.
W tym przypadku podajemy
Ket 0 do circuit.
To jest dość powszechne. Często przyjmujemy Ket 0 za
stan zainicjalizowany qubitu, ale nie jest to konieczne.
Możemy też rozważyć
zastosowanie circuit do innego stanu.
Jeśli chcemy, możemy też
zaznaczyć stan wyjściowy, który otrzymujemy, tak jak tutaj.
Oto kolejny przykład, gdzie
tym razem mamy dwa qubity o nazwach X i Y, jak
widać na diagramie.
Tutaj mamy gate Hadamard stosowany do qubitu Y, po którym następuje gate oznaczony
tym symbolem tutaj,
czyli gate Controlled NOT. Mówiliśmy o operacji
Controlled NOT w poprzedniej lekcji,
i tutaj na diagramie możemy
zobaczyć, że qubit kontrolny to Y, zaznaczony
małym wypełnionym kółkiem,
a qubit docelowy to X, zaznaczony dużym kółkiem z czymś, co wygląda jak znak plus.
Trochę wygląda to jak
symbol XOR, więc ma sens.
WEBVTT
Możesz sobie wyobrazić, że cokolwiek
klasyczny stan jest przechowywany w Y, jest poddawany operacji XOR na qubicie X.
I właśnie dla jasności, oto diagram pokazujący działanie tego gate'u na stanach standardowej bazy,
gdzie zakładamy, że A
i B są wartościami binarnymi.
Dla innych stanów działanie jest wyznaczane
przez liniowość, jak zawsze.
Teraz, zanim pójdziemy dalej, warto
wyraźnie sformułować konwencję, której będziemy przestrzegać dotyczącą kolejności qubits
w diagramach quantum circuit takich jak ten.
Konwencja jest taka, że
kolejność od dołu do góry w diagramie quantum circuit odpowiada kolejności od lewej do prawej
jak w krotce lub iloczynie tensorowym.
To jest konwencja, której
będziemy przestrzegać w serii, i jest to też konwencja
stosowana w Qiskit.
Dla tego konkretnego circuit tutaj myślimy o nim jako
działającym na parze qubits X, Y,
X jest pierwszy, bo jest na dole, a Y jest drugi w tym przypadku, bo jest na górze.
Możesz wizualnie wyobrazić sobie
to w ten sposób, jeśli pomaga: wyobraź sobie obrót
tego circuit zgodnie z ruchem wskazówek zegara, tak że wejścia są na górze,
a wyjścia na dole, i kolejność
qubits będzie właściwa.
Czasami ta kolejność sprawia trudności, więc po prostu pamiętaj o
tej konwencji.
Kiedy myślimy o działaniu opisywanym przez ten circuit, mamy najpierw
gate Hadamard zastosowany do Y,
a następnie gate Controlled NOT
na dwóch qubitach, gdzie Y jest qubitiem kontrolnym,
a X jest qubitiem docelowym.
Jeśli chcemy zapisać macierz unitarną opisującą łączne
działanie tych dwóch gate'ów, możemy to zrobić.
Najpierw rozważamy gate Hadamard na Y.
Stosujemy gate Hadamard do Y i nic nie robimy z X, co jest równoważne z
wykonaniem operacji identyczności na X.
Zatem działanie gate'u Hadamard na obu qubitach jednocześnie jest
dane przez iloczyn tensorowy macierzy identyczności i
macierzy reprezentującej
operację Hadamard na Y.
Wygląda to tak, mając na uwadze naszą
konwencję, że X jest pierwszy, a Y drugi, więc to
identyczność tensorowana z H.
Następnie stosujemy
operację Controlled NOT, która ma tę reprezentację macierzową, i ponownie jest to zgodne z naszą konwencją.
Drugi qubit Y jest qubitiem kontrolnym, a pierwszy qubit X jest qubitiem docelowym.
Nie bój się zatrzymać wideo i sprawdzić, czy to ma sens — nie będę ci już o tym przypominać.
Możesz zatrzymywać te filmy, wracać i oglądać fragmenty
tyle razy, ile chcesz, dostosować prędkość odtwarzania, używać ich w dowolny
sposób, który najlepiej ci odpowiada.
W każdym razie, kiedy składamy te
dwie operacje razem, łączne działanie jest opisane
przez ten iloczyn tutaj,
i te dwie macierze są
mnożone w tej kolejności, bo Hadamard jest wykonywany pierwszy, a Controlled NOT
jest wykonywany drugi,
i ponownie jest to zgodne
z tym, o czym mówiliśmy w lekcji pierwszej, gdzie kolejność
zasadniczo się odwraca.
Jeśli wykonamy mnożenie macierzy, otrzymamy tę macierz tutaj.
I teraz możemy odczytać z tej macierzy, co circuit robi ze
stanami standardowej bazy.
Jeśli uruchomimy circuit na wejściu 0, 0, czyli Ket 0 dla pierwszego qubitu, Ket 0 dla drugiego qubitu,
wynikiem jest stan Bella Phi+, co możemy zobaczyć w
pierwszej kolumnie macierzy.
Jeśli podamy 0, 1, otrzymamy stan Phi-, jedynka zero daje nam stan Si+,
a 1, 1 daje nam nie Psi-, ale -1 razy Psi-.
Ten minus nie jest
naprawdę istotny. Jeśli nie chcesz go tutaj mieć, możesz wykonać operację swap
na dwóch qubitach,
żeby się go pozbyć i
nie popsuje to tego, co stało się z pierwszymi trzema stanami standardowej bazy.
Ale to naprawdę nie jest ważne
dla celów tego przykładu.
Podsumowując, circuit ma to działanie tutaj na stanach standardowej bazy.
Kiedy myślisz o tym, co robi konkretny circuit, nie musisz przechodzić przez
konwersję do macierzy i je mnożyć,
możesz też śledzić
działanie, jakie circuit ma na konkretnych stanach, i w wielu przypadkach będzie to
preferowana opcja.
W tym przykładzie na przykład możemy zobaczyć, co circuit
robi ze stanem 0, 0, badając działanie gate'ów.
Stan początkowy, który
tutaj nazwaliśmy Pi zero, po prostu żeby uniknąć nazwy
kolidującej ze stanami Bella, to 0, 0.
Stosujemy gate Hadamard i stan, który otrzymujemy, to 0+, który możemy rozwinąć jak tutaj,
a następnie operacja Controlled NOT przekształca ten stan w stan Phi+, co możemy zobaczyć myśląc
o działaniu, jakie Controlled NOT ma na
stanach standardowej bazy,
i możesz zrobić to samo
dla pozostałych trzech stanów standardowej bazy lub dowolnego
innego stanu.
Możemy też włączać klasyczne bity do diagramów quantum circuit.
Są oznaczane
podwójnymi liniami, jak widzisz na tym diagramie.
To znaczy A i B są klasycznymi bitami, a X i Y są qubitami.
WEBVTT
Mamy te same dwa unitarne gate'y co w poprzednim przykładzie, a te symbole tutaj reprezentują pomiary standardowej bazy.
Konkretnie po wykonaniu dwóch
operacji unitarnych przeprowadzany jest pomiar standardowej bazy na Y,
a wynik jest nadpisywany
do klasycznego bitu B; podobnie X jest mierzony i wynik jest zapisywany do bitu A.
Tutaj widzisz, że qubity X i Y kontynuują po zmierzeniu.
Dość często
jednak nie zależy nam zbytnio na qubitach
po ich zmierzeniu.
Czasami zależy nam tylko
na wyniku pomiaru. W takim przypadku możemy użyć skróconego
stylu, który widzisz tutaj,
gdzie pomiary mają qubity wchodzące i klasyczne bity wychodzące.
Rozumienie tutaj jest takie, że
po zmierzeniu qubitów są one po prostu odrzucane lub ignorowane, a klasyczny wynik pomiaru
jest przenoszony dalej.
W miarę kontynuacji serii będziemy widzieć wiele
przykładów quantum circuits i zazwyczaj
będą one znacznie bardziej skomplikowane niż bardzo proste
przykłady, które właśnie widzieliśmy.
Jak wspomniałem wcześniej, różne symbole są
używane dla różnych gate'ów.
Gate'y na pojedynczym qubicie są zazwyczaj
zapisywane jako kwadraty z literą wskazującą,
o jaką operację chodzi.
Czasami te różne
gate'y są kodowane kolorami, żeby oznaczały różne rzeczy, ale
na razie to pominiemy.
Widzieliśmy już
gate Controlled NOT.
Gate'y swap są oznaczane
tak jak widzisz tutaj, a gate'y Toffoli i gate'y Fredkin
są oznaczane tak jak widzisz tutaj.
Pamiętaj, że gate Toffoli to gate Controlled Controlled NOT, a gate Fredkin to
gate controlled swap.
Więc te symbole są
spójne z ideą, że qubit kontrolny jest
oznaczony wypełnionym kółkiem połączonym linią
z gate'em, który kontroluje.
Ogólnie qubity kontrolne
nie muszą być na górze, a te gate'y nie muszą
działać na sąsiednich qubitach, co oznacza, że gate'y te
mogą być rozciągnięte przez
inne qubity, na które nie działają, i zobaczymy to
w przyszłych lekcjach.
Jeszcze jedna rzecz, którą często robimy używając modelu quantum circuit, to traktowanie dowolnych operacji unitarnych
na dowolnej liczbie qubitów
tak jak gdyby były pojedynczymi gate'ami, tak jak widzisz tutaj.
Po prostu rysując prostokąt z etykietą odpowiadającą
danej operacji unitarnej.
W tym przypadku jest to jakaś
operacja unitarna U.
Oczywiście nie wiemy,
czym jest U na podstawie tego diagramu — musimy założyć, że
U jest zdefiniowane w jakiś sposób lub że rozważamy jakąś dowolną
operację unitarną U. Mogłoby być na przykład tak, że
po prostu chcemy myśleć o U jak o procedurze
w interesie przejrzystości.
Używamy też tej notacji,
którą widzisz tutaj, dla operacji controlled U,
gdzie qubit kontrolny jest oznaczony wypełnionym kółkiem,
tak jak poprzednio.
To jest krótkie wprowadzenie
do modelu quantum circuit. I jak powiedziałem wcześniej, zobaczymy wiele więcej
przykładów quantum circuits,
gdy będziemy kontynuować serię.
W następnej części lekcji przyjrzymy się
iloczynowi skalarnemu, ortonormalnością i rzutom, które są bardzo ważnymi pojęciami
w kwantowej informacji i obliczeniach.
Zaczniemy od iloczynów skalarnych.
Pamiętaj, że gdy używamy
notacji Diraca, Ket jest wektorem kolumnowym,
a Bra jest wektorem wierszowym,
a konkretnie wektor
Bra odpowiadający danemu wektorowi kolumnowemu jest sprzężeniem hermitowskim
tego wektora kolumnowego.
Dla tego wektora tutaj otrzymujemy odpowiadający wektor Bra, transponując wektor
jakby był macierzą,
co sprowadza się do położenia go na bok, a następnie wzięcia sprzężenia zespolonego każdego z elementów.
Teraz przypuśćmy, że mamy dwa Kety z tą samą liczbą elementów, jak tutaj.
Jeśli tworzymy ten nawias tutaj, który po prostu oznacza, że
bierzemy iloczyn Bry i Keta,
jakby były macierzami,
to otrzymujemy to wyrażenie,
które widzisz tutaj — jest to skalar, czyli
innymi słowy liczba zespolona.
Ta wartość jest nazywana iloczynem skalarnym
tych dwóch wektorów.
Możesz też myśleć o iloczynach skalarnych w kategoriach wektorów w postaci,
którą widzisz tutaj, gdzie wektory są wyrażone
jako kombinacje liniowe
wektorów standardowej bazy.
Iloczyn skalarny tych wektorów jest zdefiniowany w ten sam sposób co
poprzednio — Bra Psi razy Ket Phi, który możemy wyrazić
jako iloczyn jak tutaj.
I jeśli obliczymy i uprosymy, pozostaje nam to wyrażenie tutaj dla iloczynu skalarnego, analogiczne do tego, co mieliśmy wcześniej,
z tą różnicą, że tym razem
sumujemy po elementach naszego klasycznego zbioru stanów, którym jest sigma w tym konkretnym przypadku.
Oto przykład mający dać ci geometryczny obraz tego,
jak działają iloczyny skalarne.
Narysowałem tutaj okrąg
w przestrzeni dwuwymiarowej odpowiadającej qubitowi, i dopóki ograniczamy uwagę
do wektorów o wpisach będących liczbami rzeczywistymi, możemy je rysować jako punkty na tej płaszczyźnie.
WEBVTT
Weźmy Phi jako
ten wektor tutaj.
Jest to wektor jednostkowy, co możemy zobaczyć obliczając normę euklidesową — i to właśnie reprezentuje ten okrąg:
wszystkie wektory jednostkowe
o wpisach będących liczbami rzeczywistymi.
Powiedzmy też, że Psi to
ten wektor tutaj, który znowu jest wektorem jednostkowym.
To właściwie stan minus, ale tutaj nazywamy go po prostu Psi.
Jeśli obliczymy iloczyn
skalarny tych dwóch wektorów, otrzymamy jeden minus pierwiastek z trzech podzielony przez dwa razy pierwiastek z dwóch,
co wynosi w przybliżeniu -1/4.
Wartość tego iloczynu skalarnego jest równa cosinusowi kąta
między tymi dwoma wektorami, jak widzisz na rysunku.
To jest ogólnie prawda dla wektorów jednostkowych. Jeśli mamy dwa wektory jednostkowe i oba mają wpisy będące liczbami rzeczywistymi,
to iloczyn skalarny między nimi jest równy cosinusowi
kąta między nimi.
W szczególności jeśli iloczyn
skalarny jest równy zero, tak jak w tym przykładzie, gdzie zmieniliśmy Psi
na ten stan tutaj,
to dwa wektory muszą
być pod kątem 90 stopni do siebie.
To wszystko uogólnia się na
wektory w dowolnym wymiarze, nawiasem mówiąc, o ile
wpisy są liczbami rzeczywistymi — nie dotyczy to tylko wektorów dwuwymiarowych.
Jeśli mamy wpisy będące liczbami zespolonymi, obraz nie działa już tak dobrze, ale mimo to iloczyn skalarny jest równie
użyteczny, jak zobaczymy.
Iloczyn skalarny ma kilka
bardzo ważnych właściwości i poświęcimy chwilę na zaobserwowanie niektórych z tych właściwości.
Pierwsza to związek
między iloczynem skalarnym a normą euklidesową.
Jeśli weźmiemy iloczyn skalarny
dowolnego wektora z samym sobą, otrzymamy kwadrat normy euklidesowej.
Możemy więc alternatywnie powiedzieć, że norma euklidesowa wektora jest równa pierwiastkowi kwadratowemu z iloczynu skalarnego
tego wektora z samym sobą. To nie jest przypadek — to jest
fundamentalny związek, i tutaj możemy zobaczyć, że gdyby nie było
sprzężeń zespolonych w definicji iloczynu skalarnego, to ta formuła
przestałaby być prawdziwa i nie mielibyśmy tak użytecznego pojęcia
z tym fundamentalnym związkiem
z normą euklidesową.
Następna właściwość: iloczyn skalarny
jest sprzężenie symetryczny, co oznacza, że jeśli zamienimy
kolejność dwóch argumentów, to wartość iloczynu skalarnego zostaje sprzężona.
Jest to wyrażone przez
to równanie tutaj i jest dość łatwo zobaczyć, dlaczego to się dzieje dla tych dwóch wyrażeń
dla iloczynu skalarnego dwóch wektorów w dwóch możliwych kolejnościach.
Iloczyn skalarny jest liniowy
w drugim argumencie. Konkretnie jeśli zdefiniujemy wektor Phi jako tę kombinację liniową dwóch wektorów,
Phi jeden i Phi dwa, to iloczyn skalarny
dowolnego wektora Psi z Phi jest taką samą kombinacją liniową
dwóch iloczynów skalarnych,
i wynika to dość
bezpośrednio z faktu, że mnożenie macierzy jest liniowe.
I mamy też to, że iloczyn
skalarny jest sprzężenie liniowy w pierwszym argumencie, co możesz zobaczyć wyrażone tutaj.
Jeśli Psi jest tą kombinacją
liniową wektorów, to jeśli weźmiemy iloczyn
skalarny Psi i Phi,
to Bra Psi staje się tym wektorem, który widzimy tutaj, gdzie bierzemy sprzężenie
zespolone beta jeden i beta dwa,
i to jest wynik — na tym polega sprzężona liniowość.
Ostatnia właściwość iloczynu skalarnego, o której chcę wspomnieć, to
niesamowicie użyteczna nierówność Cauchy'ego-Schwarza.
Dla dowolnych dwóch wektorów Psi i Phi, wartość bezwzględna iloczynu skalarnego nie może być większa niż iloczyn norm euklidesowych
tych dwóch wektorów. Co więcej, jedynym sposobem, żeby obie
strony nierówności były równe, jest liniowa zależność tych dwóch
wektorów,
co oznacza, że jeden z nich jest równy jakiemuś skalarowi pomnożonemu przez drugi.
To jest w istocie jedna z
najszerzej używanych nierówności w całej matematyce, i używamy jej raz po raz mówiąc o
kwantowej informacji,
więc bardzo dobrze ją znać.
Następnie porozmawiamy o
pojęciach ortogonalności i ortonormalności, które są
powiązane z iloczynami skalarnymi
i konkretnie z
iloczynami skalarnymi wektorów równymi zero.
Dokładnie mówiąc, jeśli mamy
dwa wektory Psi i Phi, mówimy, że są ortogonalne,
jeśli ich iloczyn skalarny
jest równy zero. Intuicyjnie możemy myśleć
o ortogonalnych wektorach jako będących
pod kątem prostym do siebie,
lub alternatywnie, że są
prostopadłe do siebie.
Ludzie czasami używają terminu ortogonalny w odniesieniu do rzeczy, które
nie mają ze sobą nic wspólnego — jak mówienie, że jedna kwestia
jest ortogonalna do innej —
ale to jest oczywiście dość nieformalne i tak naprawdę pozbawione sensu
matematycznego; związek jest jednak jasny, jeśli myślisz o ortogonalnych
wektorach jako wskazujących
nie w przeciwnych kierunkach, ale w zupełnie różnych kierunkach — jak północ versus zachód na przykład.
Jeśli mamy zbiór wektorów, mówimy, że zbiór jest ortogonalny, jeśli dowolne dwa różne wektory
wybrane z tego zbioru
są koniecznie ortogonalne do siebie, co możemy wyrazić
tak jak widzisz tutaj,
WEBVTT
Zbiór ortonormalny to
po prostu ortogonalny zbiór wektorów jednostkowych.
Wektory w zbiorach ortogonalnych
nie muszą koniecznie być wektorami jednostkowymi — i w rzeczywistości
wektor zerowy
może być elementem zbioru ortogonalnego, ale w zbiorze ortonormalnym każdy wektor musi być wektorem jednostkowym,
poza wymaganiem, żeby
zbiór był ortogonalny.
Biorąc pod uwagę to, co wiemy o związku między iloczynem skalarnym
a normą euklidesową, możemy wyrazić ten
warunek dość zwięźle
tak jak widzisz tutaj.
I na koniec, baza ortonormalna to po prostu zbiór ortonormalny
tworzący bazę dla dowolnej przestrzeni wektorowej,
o której mówimy.
Na przykład jeśli weźmiemy dowolny
klasyczny zbiór stanów sigma i rozważymy zbiór
wszystkich wektorów standardowej bazy,
widzimy, że jest to zbiór ortonormalny, a w rzeczywistości jest to baza ortonormalna dla przestrzeni wszystkich wektorów, których wpisy odpowiadają
temu klasycznemu zbiorowi stanów sigma.
Wszystkie te wektory są jednostkowe i
są parami ortogonalne, więc jest to zbiór ortonormalny.
i ponieważ jest to też baza, mamy, że jest to baza ortonormalna.
Zbiory ortonormalne są
zawsze liniowo niezależne nawiasem mówiąc, więc zawsze gdy
masz zbiór ortonormalny, będzie on zawsze bazą ortonormalną pewnej podprzestrzeni,
ale w tym przypadku mamy bazę dla całej przestrzeni, w której pracujemy.
Innym przykładem jest zbiór
zawierający Ket+ i Ket-.
Te dwa wektory są ortogonalne — ich iloczyn skalarny jest równy zero.
i oba są wektorami jednostkowymi i rozpinają
dwuwymiarową przestrzeń wektora odpowiadającą pojedynczemu qubitowi, więc tworzą bazę ortonormalną
dla tej przestrzeni.
Innym przykładem jest baza Bella, która jest bazą ortonormalną dla przestrzeni wszystkich
czterowymiarowych wektorów odpowiadających dwóm qubitom.
Zbiór zawierający Ket 0
i Ket+ natomiast nie jest zbiorem ortogonalnym, bo iloczyn skalarny
tych wektorów jest niezerowy.
Oba są wektorami jednostkowymi i jest to baza dla przestrzeni wektorowej odpowiadającej qubitowi, ale nie mamy ortogonalności.
Oto przydatny fakt o zbiorach ortonormalnych, z którego będziemy korzystać od czasu do czasu.
Przypuśćmy, że mamy pewien
zbiór ortonormalny wektorów — konkretnie przypuśćmy,
że mamy M wektorów w tym zbiorze: Psi jeden przez Psi M,
gdzie zakładamy, że te wektory są z jakiejś N-
wymiarowej przestrzeni wektorowej, czyli innymi słowy, każdy
z wektorów ma N wpisów.
Jak już wspomniałem, zbiory ortonormalne są zawsze
liniowo niezależne, więc nie może być tak, że M jest większe niż N,
ale może być tak, że M jest mniejsze niż N, i to jest przypadek,
który nas interesuje.
I co stwierdza ten fakt:
jeśli M jest mniejsze niż N, to zawsze można
dodać dodatkowe wektory
do zbioru, od którego zaczęliśmy, żeby uzyskać
bazę ortonormalną dla naszej przestrzeni.
Mówiąc dokładnie, muszą
istnieć wektory Psi M+1 do Psi N tak, że cały zbiór
tworzy bazę ortonormalną.
Więc nigdy nie możesz wpędzić się
w kozi róg, że tak powiem, wybierając
zbiór ortonormalny wektorów, którego nie można rozszerzyć
do bazy ortonormalnej.
Czasami można po prostu spojrzeć
na zbiór, od którego zaczynasz, i wymyślić, jak go rozszerzyć do bazy ortonormalnej, ale alternatywą, która zawsze działa,
jest użycie procedury zwanej procesem
ortonormalizacji Grama-Schmidta do konstrukcji tych wektorów.
Nie wyjaśnię tej
procedury w tej lekcji ani w tej serii, bo szczegóły nie są
naprawdę dla nas ważne, ale oczywiście możesz
ją sprawdzić, jeśli jesteś ciekaw/ciekawa.
To jest coś, co może
być wykonane przez komputer w razie potrzeby, więc
nie ma w tym twórczości — to tylko mechaniczna procedura.
Jednym z powodów, dla których
jest to tak przydatny fakt, jest ścisły związek, który istnieje między bazami
ortonormalnymi a macierzami unitarnymi.
W szczególności dla dowolnej macierzy kwadratowej U trzy warunki, które widzisz tutaj, są zawsze równoważne,
co oznacza, że albo
wszystkie są prawdziwe, albo wszystkie są fałszywe.
Pierwszy warunek mówi,
że U jest macierzą unitarną, co oznacza, że zarówno U dagger razy U, jak i U razy U dagger są obie
równe macierzy identyczności.
Drugi warunek
mówi, że wiersze U tworzą bazę ortonormalną,
a trzeci warunek mówi, że kolumny U
tworzą bazę ortonormalną.
Nie jest w rzeczywistości zbyt trudne
zobaczyć, dlaczego ta równoważność jest prawdziwa.
Żeby zachować prostotę, przyjrzyjmy się
macierzy trójwymiarowej U, tak jak widzisz tutaj, gdzie wpisy mogą być dowolnymi
liczbami zespolonymi.
Tutaj po lewej stronie zapisałem U transponowane sprzężenie
dla wygody.
Jeśli tworzymy trzy wektory
z kolumn U — tutaj nazwane Psi
jeden, Psi dwa i Psi trzy — i weźmiemy
iloczyn U dagger i U,
możesz sprawdzić, że każdy
wpis iloczynu jest dany przez iloczyn skalarny wektorów tak jak widzimy tutaj w tym wzorcu.
I teraz kiedy myślisz o warunku, że U jest unitarne, co jest równoważne temu, że ta macierz jest równa macierzy identyczności,
widzisz, że jest to równoważne
temu, że trzy wektory tworzą zbiór ortonormalny.
Wpisy diagonalne muszą być
równe jeden, więc to są koniecznie wektory jednostkowe, a wpisy poza przekątną muszą być równe zero,
więc jest to ortogonalny zbiór wektorów.
WEBVTT
Zatem unitarność U jest równoważna temu, że kolumny tworzą zbiór ortonormalny,
i to musi być baza, bo liczba wektorów w zbiorze — trzy w tym przypadku — zgadza się z wymiarem przestrzeni,
w której pracujemy. Możesz zastosować podobny argument dla wierszy zamiast kolumn, żeby stwierdzić, że unitarność U jest równoważna
temu, że wiersze tworzą bazę ortonormalną.
Nie działa to tak ładnie, bo musimy wprowadzić pewne dostosowanie, żeby sprzężenia zespolone
działały właściwie, ale idea jest taka sama.
Alternatywnym podejściem, które jest dość proste, jest udowodnienie, że macierz jest unitarna wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy jej transpozycja jest unitarna.
I tutaj naprawdę mówię transpozycja, a nie sprzężenie hermitowskie.
Jest dość trywialnym faktem wynikającym z
definicji macierzy unitarnych, że sprzężenie hermitowskie
dowolnej macierzy unitarnej jest unitarne,
ale jest też prawdą, że transpozycja dowolnej macierzy unitarnej jest unitarna.
W każdym razie mamy
równoważność między tymi trzema warunkami dla dowolnej macierzy kwadratowej U, i możemy połączyć tę równoważność
z faktem o
rozszerzaniu zbiorów ortonormalnych do baz ortonormalnych, żeby konstruować macierze unitarne
które robią ciekawe rzeczy
lub spełniają różne potrzeby, które możemy napotkać.
Konkretnie ilekroć mamy
zbiór ortonormalny M wektorów, zawsze będzie istniała macierz unitarna U
której pierwsze M kolumn to wektory z tego zbioru ortonormalnego.
Pozostałe kolumny
zawsze można uzupełnić tak, żeby uzyskać macierz unitarną, wybierając je tak, żeby kolumny tworzyły
bazę ortonormalną. To będzie całkiem
przydatny fakt do dyspozycji.
I jeszcze jeden temat
w tej części lekcji — pojęcie rzutu.
O macierzy kwadratowej Pi mówi się,
że jest rzutem lub macierzą rzutu, jeśli dwa warunki
wymienione tutaj są oba prawdziwe.
To jest wielka litera Pi nawiasem mówiąc — to dość typowy wybór litery używanej do oznaczania rzutu.
Często nadajemy tego rodzaju typowe nazwy obiektom takim jak macierze, żeby łatwiej je rozpoznawać i zachować porządek,
ale możesz użyć dowolnej nazwy. W każdym razie pierwszy warunek jest taki, że Pi jest równe swojemu sprzężeniu hermitowskiemu.
Ogólnie gdy mamy macierz równą swojemu
własnemu sprzężeniu hermitowskiemu, mówimy, że jest macierzą hermitowską.
Więc pierwszy warunek można alternatywnie sformułować jako: Pi jest hermitowska.
Drugi warunek jest taki,
że jeśli podniesiemy Pi do kwadratu, czyli pomnożymy Pi
przez siebie, otrzymamy Pi z powrotem.
Więc podniesienie Pi do kwadratu nic jej nie robi.
Intuicyjnie idea rzutu
jest taka, że jest podobna duchem do rzutowania obrazu na ekran lub opuszczania prostopadłej na linię
na przykład. Kiedy mnożysz
wektor przez rzut, robisz w pewnym sensie
coś, co zostawia jedną część w spokoju
i zeruje resztę.
Więc jeśli zastosujesz
rzut po raz drugi, nic nie robi, bo
już wyzerowałeś/wyzerowałaś część, którą rzut zeruje.
Przykładem rzutu
jest ta macierz tutaj dla dowolnego wyboru wektora jednostkowego Psi.
Możemy sprawdzić, że spełnia
wymagane warunki jeden po drugim.
Dla pierwszego obliczamy
sprzężenie hermitowskie i jest to sprzężenie hermitowskie iloczynu.
Możemy więc użyć tej formuły tutaj dla sprzężenia hermitowskiego
iloczynu, żeby nam pomóc.
To, co otrzymujesz, to iloczyn sprzężeń hermitowskich, ale kolejność jest odwrócona.
Dzieje się tak z powodu
części transpozycji.
Jeśli zastosujemy tę formułę, otrzymujemy tę równość tutaj i możemy następnie uprościć, żeby
wrócić do oryginalnej macierzy.
Zauważ nawiasem mówiąc, że nie użyliśmy faktu,
że Psi jest wektorem jednostkowym.
Więc w rzeczywistości ta macierz jest
hermitowska dla dowolnego wektora Psi, nie tylko dla wektorów jednostkowych.
I dla drugiego warunki podnosimy Pi do kwadratu i otrzymujemy
to wyrażenie tutaj, które jest równe oryginalnej macierzy tym razem
dlatego, że Psi jest wektorem jednostkowym, więc ten iloczyn skalarny
tutaj jest równy jeden — i tutaj pojawia się założenie,
że Psi jest wektorem jednostkowym.
To jest tutaj istotne.
Możemy uogólnić ten przykład i zacząć od zbioru ortonormalnego.
I jeśli tworzymy tę macierz tutaj, gdzie sumujemy rzuty odpowiadające poszczególnym wektorom, to otrzymujemy rzut.
Tutaj na ekranie możesz zobaczyć obliczenia, które to ujawniają, i zostawiam to tobie
do zbadania, jeśli chcesz.
I podobnie jak w pierwszym przykładzie, to drugi warunek wykorzystuje ortonormalność
zbioru.
Co robi ten rzut,
jeśli pomnożysz go przez wektor: rzutuje ten
wektor na podprzestrzeń rozpinana przez ten zbiór wektorów,
co w abstrakcyjny sposób jest
podobne do opuszczania prostopadłej na tę podprzestrzeń, a gdy
już jesteś w tej podprzestrzeni, rzut nic nie robi.
Więc macierze takie jak te są
przykładami rzutów, i teraz w istocie wyczerpaliśmy
wszystkie możliwości.
Każda macierz rzutu przyjmuje tę formę dla jakiegoś wyboru zbioru ortonormalnego.
Macierz zerowa jest rzutem, więc musimy
upewnić się, że ją uwzględniamy, jeśli chcemy mieć każdy rzut.
WEBVTT
Żeby było jasne, dopuszczamy
możliwość, że M równa się zero, co daje nam pustą sumę,
którą możemy interpretować jako macierz zerową.
Teraz gdy mamy
pojęcie rzutu do dyspozycji, możemy zdefiniować bardziej ogólną
klasę pomiarów kwantowych znanych jako pomiary rzutowe.
To nie jest najbardziej ogólne
pojęcie pomiaru, ale jest znacznie bardziej ogólne niż pomiary standardowej bazy
i będzie bardzo
pomocne, żeby włączyć je do naszego opisu
kwantowej informacji.
Pomiar rzutowy jest definiowany przez dowolny zbiór rzutów
spełniający warunek, który widzisz tutaj — czyli rzuty
sumują się do macierzy identyczności.
Tutaj M może być dowolną
dodatnią liczbą całkowitą, o ile to wszystko są rzuty i ten warunek jest spełniony —
zbiór definiuje
pomiar rzutowy.
Pomiar opisany
przez taki zbiór działa następująco, kiedy
mierzysz dowolny stan kwantowy Psi.
Najpierw otrzymujesz wynik
między jeden a M, gdzie M jest liczbą rzutów.
Dla każdego możliwego wyniku K prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania tego wyniku to kwadrat normy euklidesowej wektora, który otrzymujesz
mnożąc S przez Pi
K — K-ty rzut.
Możemy też zapisać tę
wielkość tak jak widzisz tutaj.
Ta równość wynika z związku między normą
euklidesową a iloczynem skalarnym wraz z faktem,
że Pi K jest rzutem.
Z drugiej postaci, wraz z warunkiem, który mamy na tych rzutach, możemy od razu zobaczyć, z liniowości, że nasze prawdopodobieństwa
zawsze sumują się do jeden,
mając na uwadze, że Psi
musi być wektorem jednostkowym.
I po drugie, zakładając, że
otrzymujemy wynik K, stan układu
zapada się do stanu kwantowego, który uzyskujemy przez znormalizowanie wektora, który dostaliśmy przez rzutowanie.
Za chwilę przyjrzymy się kilku
przykładom, ale zanim to zrobimy, chcę wspomnieć, że tak naprawdę nie musimy
numerować możliwych
wyników od jeden do M. Możemy wybrać dowolne nazwy lub symbole dla wyników.
W szczególności jeśli mamy zbiór rzutów oznaczonych symbolami
z jakiegoś zbioru gamma,
i spełniają one
ten sam warunek co poprzednio — czyli sumują
się do macierzy identyczności — to mamy pomiar rzutowy,
który działa dokładnie
tak samo jak poprzednio.
Jedyną różnicą tutaj jest to, że dopuszczamy,
żeby wyniki pomiaru były elementami tego zbioru gamma, a nie liczbami całkowitymi od jeden do M.
W naszym pierwszym przykładzie
pomiaru rzutowego zaobserwujmy, że
pomiary standardowej bazy są pomiarami rzutowymi.
W tym przypadku zbiór
wyników pomiaru jest taki sam jak zbiór klasycznych stanów dowolnego układu, który jest mierzony.
I zbiór rzutów
opisujących pomiar to ta kolekcja tutaj, zakładając, że sigma jest
klasycznym zbiorem stanów
naszego układu. To wszystko są rzuty
i jeśli je zsumujemy, otrzymamy macierz identyczności, więc jest to prawidłowy pomiar rzutowy.
Żeby zobaczyć, jak to działa
bardziej szczegółowo, przypuśćmy, że
mamy jakiś dowolny stan zapisany w postaci,
którą widzisz tutaj.
Prawdopodobieństwo, że
pomiar da wynik A, zgodnie z opisem
sprzed chwili, to ta wartość tutaj,
która jest równa
kwadratowi wartości bezwzględnej odpowiadającego
wpisu wektora Psi — co jest zgodne z oczekiwaniami.
Pod warunkiem, że wynikiem jest A, stan układu staje się tym, znowu zgodnie z
opisem sprzed chwili.
Jeśli uprościmy, nie dostajemy
dokładnie stanu, którego oczekujemy, czyli Ket A.
Zamiast tego otrzymujemy Ket A
pomnożone przez skalar — konkretnie jest to skalar o
wartości bezwzględnej równej jeden,
więc to liczba zespolona
na okręgu jednostkowym.
To się nazywa globalną fazą i omówimy globalne fazy wkrótce, ale na razie krótko mówiąc, ten
stan jest równoważny Ket A.
Ta globalna faza tak naprawdę nie ma żadnego znaczenia i zobaczymy dlaczego,
gdy dojdziemy do dyskusji o globalnych fazach.
Więc pomijając tę kwestię globalnych faz, o których porozmawiamy za chwilę, widzimy, że pomiary standardowej bazy
są w istocie pomiarami rzutowymi. Dla kolejnego przykładu, który jest naprawdę rozszerzeniem
poprzedniego,
jeśli przeprowadzimy pomiar standardowej bazy
na układzie X i nic nie robimy z układem Y, tak jak omawialiśmy
w poprzedniej lekcji,
jest to całkowicie równoważne
mierzeniu układu X, Y.
Z tym pomiarem rzutowym
tutaj.
Mamy te rzuty odpowiadające klasycznym stanom X i tensorujemy z identycznością na Y,
co odzwierciedla fakt, że
nic nie robimy z Y.
Opis tego, jak
pomiary rzutowe działają ogólnie, mówi nam
co się dzieje w tym przykładzie, i zostawiam tobie
sprawdzenie, że jest to w istocie
całkowicie równoważne temu, o czym mówiliśmy w poprzedniej lekcji.
To wszystko jest bardzo miłe, bo ten opis pomiaru rzutowego jest czystszy w pewnym sensie i widzimy, że wpisuje się
w ten bardziej ogólny obraz.
WEBVTT
Oto jeszcze jeden przykład
pomiaru rzutowego.
Ten jest pomiarem dwóch qubitów.
Dla tego pomiaru
mamy dwa rzuty, a zatem dwa możliwe
wyniki: zero i jeden.
Rzuty są definiowane
w kategoriach stanów Bella, jak widzisz tutaj.
Pierwszy rzut jest
na przestrzeń rozpinaną przez trzy symetryczne stany Bella, a drugi rzut jest
na jednowymiarową przestrzeń
rozpinaną przez stan Psi-, który jest antysymetryczny — czyli innymi słowy,
ten, który jest mnożony
przez minus jeden, jeśli
przeprowadzamy operację swap na dwóch qubitach.
Zobaczymy później w serii, dlaczego jest to ciekawy pomiar.
Na razie to tylko przykład
nawiązujący do czegoś, co widzieliśmy wcześniej —
bazy Bella.
Ostatnia uwaga o pomiarach rzutowych: zawsze gdy masz
pomiar rzutowy, zawsze możesz go zaimplementować
za pomocą operacji unitarnych i
pomiarów standardowej bazy.
Dla tego konkretnego przykładu
pomiaru na przykład możemy zbudować quantum circuit implementujący pomiar,
jak widzisz tutaj.
Wyobraź sobie, że górne
dwa qubity to qubity, które mierzymy tym pomiarem rzutowym, i co możemy zrobić, to
wprowadzić nowy qubit,
który zaczyna zainicjalizowany
do stanu zero. Wykonujemy gate Hadamard
po którym następuje gate Fredkin, po którym następuje kolejny gate Hadamard,
i jeśli mierzymy ten dolny qubit za pomocą pomiaru standardowej bazy, efekt będzie dokładnie taki sam, jak gdybyśmy mierzyli dwa górne qubity
z pomiarem rzutowym
z tego przykładu.
Uzyskamy dokładnie takie same prawdopodobieństwa dla dwóch wyników, a efekt, jaki pomiar ma na dwa górne qubity,
będzie taki sam.
To wcale nie jest oczywiste. Wymaga analizy i ta analiza nie jest tutaj pokazana.
Jak już sugerowałem, przyjrzymy się bliżej
temu konkretnemu pomiarowi w późniejszej lekcji — na razie
służy on tylko jako przykład.
Ważny wniosek jest taki, że coś takiego jest zawsze możliwe dla dowolnego pomiaru rzutowego, więc tak naprawdę nie zyskujemy
żadnych dodatkowych możliwości,
wprowadzając pomiary rzutowe, ale jest to bardzo użyteczne pojęcie i często będziemy mówić o pomiarach rzutowych,
kontynuując serię. Ostatnia część tej lekcji dotyczy kilku ważnych ograniczeń
kwantowej informacji
i tego, co możemy robić z quantum circuits.
Pierwsze ograniczenie — które może nie tyle jest ograniczeniem, ile raczej degeneracją — dotyczy kwestii globalnych faz,
o których wspomniałem niedawno. Oto definicja tego, co mamy na myśli, gdy mówimy o globalnej fazie.
Jeśli mamy dwa wektory
stanu kwantowego Psi i Phi takie, że jeden z nich jest
równy drugiemu pomnożonemu przez jakąś liczbę zespoloną alfa,
mówimy wtedy, że stany
różnią się globalną fazą, lub alternatywnie, że są równoważne z dokładnością do globalnej fazy.
Zauważ, że ponieważ wektory stanu kwantowego mają normę euklidesową równą jeden, jedynym sposobem, żeby to
równanie mogło być prawdziwe,
jest to, żeby wartość bezwzględna
tej liczby zespolonej była równa jeden — więc alfa
musi leżeć na okręgu jednostkowym.
Wyobraź sobie, że mamy
dwa stany kwantowe takie, że różnią się globalną fazą, i przypuśćmy, że mierzymy stan Phi
za pomocą pomiaru standardowej bazy.
Prawdopodobieństwo uzyskania dowolnego wyniku A jest dane przez to wyrażenie tutaj, i jeśli podstawimy
alfa razy Psi za Phi,
co możemy zrobić, bo
zakładamy, że są równe, otrzymujemy to prawdopodobieństwo.
I jeśli uprościmy używając faktu, że alfa leży na
jednostkowym okręgu zespolonym, otrzymujemy to prawdopodobieństwo.
Pamiętaj, że to jest prawdopodobieństwo, że mierzenie Phi daje wynik A, ale teraz widzimy, że
jest to dokładnie takie samo jak prawdopodobieństwo, że mierzenie
Psi daje wynik A,
więc nie ma absolutnie
żadnej różnicy w prawdopodobieństwach różnych wyników dla tych dwóch stanów.
Podobny argument mówi nam bardziej ogólnie, że dla dowolnego pomiaru rzutowego prawdopodobieństwa są znowu identyczne.
Więc mierząc, nie możemy
odróżnić od siebie dwóch stanów, które
różnią się globalną fazą, nawet w sensie statystycznym.
Na koniec, jeśli zastosujemy dowolną operację unitarną
do stanu Phi, to znowu przez podstawienie, co uzyskamy, to dokładnie
ta sama liczba zespolona alfa
pomnożona przez to, co uzyskamy stosując tę samą operację unitarną
do stanu Psi.
Więc te dwa stany nadal
będą różnić się globalną fazą.
Konkluzja jest taka, że te dwa stany są całkowicie nierozróżnialne, więc tak naprawdę nie ma
między nimi żadnej różnicy
w kategoriach tego, czego moglibyśmy
się o nich dowiedzieć, wykonując operacje unitarne i pomiary, i z tego powodu
uważamy te dwa
stany za równoważne — lub jeśli wolisz, że to po prostu dwie różne możliwe
reprezentacje wektorowe
tego samego stanu kwantowego.
Jak powiedziałem na
początku dyskusji, to w zasadzie degeneracja
w tym, jak stany kwantowe są opisywane przez wektory stanu kwantowego.
W każdym razie, co to oznacza: możemy
po prostu ignorować globalne fazy, tak jak robiliśmy to efektywnie opisując pomiary standardowej bazy
WEBVTT
jako pomiary rzutowe. Nawiasem mówiąc, ta degeneracja pojawia się tylko w uproszczonym opisie
kwantowej informacji.
Kiedy opisujemy stany
kwantowe za pomocą macierzy gęstości, co zrobimy w
trzeciej jednostce serii, będziemy mieć jednoznaczną
reprezentację macierzową
dla każdego stanu kwantowego. Kwestia globalnych faz
po prostu nie pojawia się w ogólnym opisie
kwantowej informacji.
To kolejny atrakcyjny aspekt
ogólnego opisu kwantowej informacji,
na który ciągle aluzjonuję, ale niezależnie od tego globalne
fazy nie będą nas niepokoić,
bo możemy po prostu skorzystać
z wolności ich ignorowania.
Oto bardzo szybki
przykład, żeby upewnić się, że pojęcie globalnej fazy jest jasne.
Jeśli mamy stan minus i minus jeden razy stan minus, to te dwa stany
różnią się globalną fazą — konkretnie alfa równa się minus jeden.
Z drugiej strony, jeśli mamy stan plus i stan minus, to nie mamy dwóch stanów
różniących się globalną fazą.
To są wektory ortogonalne, więc są liniowo niezależne.
Stwierdzenie, że dwa wektory stanu kwantowego różnią się globalną fazą,
jest równoważne stwierdzeniu, że wektory są liniowo zależne,
więc z pewnością te wektory
nie różnią się globalną fazą.
Prawdą jest, że jedyna różnica polega na tym, że ten znak plus
zamienia się w ten znak minus, ale to co nazywamy
różnicą fazy względnej.
To różni się od globalnej fazy, bo nie
mnożymy całego wektora przez liczbę zespoloną.
I to jest zgodne z faktem, że możemy odróżnić te stany — w szczególności jeśli
zastosujemy operację Hadamard
i następnie zmierzymy, zobaczymy zero, jeśli
stan był stanem plus, i jeden, jeśli stan był stanem minus.
Kolejnym ograniczeniem kwantowej informacji, które zobaczymy w tej lekcji,
jest twierdzenie o nieklonowaniu.
Oto jedno sformułowanie
twierdzenia o nieklonowaniu — to konkretne
sformułowanie jest dość konkretne i szczegółowe,
co ułatwi jego omówienie. Istnieją inne, bardziej ogólne sposoby sformułowania twierdzenia o nieklonowaniu,
ale na razie skupimy się na tym.
Zakładamy, że mamy dwa układy X i Y o tym samym klasycznym zbiorze stanów.
który składa się z
liczb całkowitych od zero do D-1, gdzie D wynosi co najmniej dwa.
Nazwy klasycznych stanów nie są naprawdę ważne, ale wybierając te nazwy, zachowamy prostotę.
Najważniejsze jest
tutaj to, że istnieją co najmniej dwa różne klasyczne
stany — czyli innymi słowy nie martwimy się o
trywialny i nieinteresujący przypadek,
gdy mamy tylko jeden klasyczny stan.
Twierdzenie mówi, że nie istnieje operacja unitarna U, którą możemy zastosować do X, Y tak, żeby po zainicjalizowaniu
Y do stanu zero,
efektywnie kopiować lub klonować
dowolne stany kwantowe X.
Jeśli przyjrzymy się temu
wyrażeniu tutaj w izolacji, mówi ono, że dla wszystkich wyborów wektora stanu kwantowego Psi X,
zastosowanie U do Psi tensorowanego
ze stanem zero daje nam Psi tensor Psi — czyli innymi słowy dwie
niezależne kopie Psi,
i to jest to, co oznaczałoby, gdybyśmy mogli klonować stany
kwantowe — a twierdzenie mówi, że to nie jest możliwe.
Możesz o tym myśleć
w kategoriach circuits — i twierdzenie mówi, że nigdy nie będziesz w stanie wymyślić gate'u ani circuit,
który działa tak jak widzisz tutaj.
Gdzie jedna kopia stanu Psi wchodzi razem ze zbiorem
zainicjalizowanych qubitów i produkowane są dwie kopie Psi.
Możesz to zrobić dla pewnych
wyborów stanu Psi, ale nigdy nie możesz wymyślić
circuit, który działa w ten sposób dla każdego stanu kwantowego Psi,
i to właśnie mówi twierdzenie.
Udowodnienie tego twierdzenia jest dość łatwe — sprowadza się w zasadzie do faktu, że szukana transformacja nie jest liniowa,
a operacje unitarne są
liniowe, więc po prostu nie może działać.
Oto argument w nieco większym szczególe.
Przypuśćmy, że mamy operację unitarną U, która klonuje stany standardowej bazy
Ket 0 i Ket jeden.
Wiemy, że klasyczne
stany zero i jeden muszą należeć do naszego klasycznego zbioru stanów, bo D wynosi co najmniej dwa.
Ale to oznacza z liniowości,
że jeśli X jest w stanie plus, który możemy zapisać tak,
to wynikiem jest ta kombinacja liniowa tych dwóch stanów tutaj.
Jednak to nie jest właściwe zachowanie. Wymaganie na U jest takie, że
U klonuje stan plus,
co oznacza, że musimy
mieć to równanie tutaj spełnione.
Te dwa stany nie są
takie same, więc to nie działa — i na tym koniec.
Jeszcze kilka dodatkowych uwag
o twierdzeniu o nieklonowaniu.
Po pierwsze, to sformułowanie twierdzenia
o nieklonowaniu jest absolutne w pewnym sensie.
Mówi po prostu, że operacja unitarna U, która działa dokładnie
tak, nie istnieje.
Możesz więc zapytać, czy
istnieje operacja unitarna U, która
robi to w przybliżeniu, biorąc pod uwagę jakiś sposób opisania
WEBVTT
przybliżenia. Istnieją różne
pojęcia przybliżenia, które mogą nas interesować,
i zobaczymy kilka
z nich w trzeciej jednostce serii, ale dla tych różnych
pojęć przybliżenia
istnieją ilościowe sformułowania
twierdzenia o nieklonowaniu, które nakładają silne ograniczenia na to, jak dobrze można w przybliżeniu klonować.
Druga uwaga: kopiowanie lub klonowanie stanów standardowej bazy jak najbardziej jest możliwe.
Na przykład gate Controlled NOT kopiuje stany standardowej bazy qubitu.
To nie jest sprzeczne
z twierdzeniem o nieklonowaniu. Chodzi o to, że klonowanie w sensie twierdzenia o nieklonowaniu wymaga,
żeby działało nie tylko
dla stanów standardowej bazy,
ale dla wszystkich stanów.
Gate Controlled NOT
z pewnością nie klonuje stanu plus na przykład.
I na koniec warto zauważyć, że istnieje też twierdzenie o nieklonowaniu dla
stanów probabilistycznych.
To po prostu nie jest coś,
o czym ludzie mówią lub co ich interesuje.
Jeśli ktoś losowo
wybiera bit — powiedzmy według jakiegoś dowolnego sposobu przypisywania prawdopodobieństw do dwóch wartości — i
następnie podaje ci ten bit,
oczywiście nie ma sposobu, żebyś uzyskał/uzyskała dwie niezależne próbki
tego losowego bitu.
Po prostu nie wiesz, jakie
są prawdopodobieństwa.
Możesz skopiować bit, tak jak gate Controlled NOT
kopiuje stany standardowej bazy, ale to nie to samo co klonowanie stanu probabilistycznego.
Po prostu nie masz wystarczająco
informacji, żeby to zrobić. Cokolwiek losowy bit, który ci dano, nie mówi ci, jakie
były prawdopodobieństwa.
To po prostu bit.
Niemożliwość klonowania
stanu probabilistycznego wynika dokładnie z tego samego rozumowania co w przypadku kwantowym.
Klonowanie jest procesem nieliniowym, natomiast operacje probabilistyczne, podobnie jak operacje unitarne, są liniowe.
W każdym razie nie jest zaskakujące,
że nie możemy klonować stanu probabilistycznego i
jakoś to nie jest tak interesujące jak fakt, że nie możemy
klonować stanu kwantowego,
ale chodzi po prostu o to, żeby zaobserwować, że nie jest to zjawisko czysto
kwantowe.
Ostatnim ograniczeniem
kwantowej informacji, które omówimy w tej lekcji, jest to, że nie jest możliwe doskonałe rozróżnienie
dwóch stanów kwantowych, które nie są ortogonalne.
Inny sposób powiedzenia tego samego
jest taki, że jeśli dwa stany kwantowe można doskonale rozróżnić, to muszą być ortogonalne.
Gdy mówimy o
doskonałym rozróżnieniu dwóch stanów kwantowych Psi i Phi, mamy na myśli to, że istnieje jakiś
sposób ich odróżnienia
bez żadnej szansy na błąd.
W kategoriach modelu quantum circuit możemy to wyrazić tak,
jak widzisz tutaj na ekranie.
Mamy jakąś operację unitarną U, która może być zaimplementowana
jako quantum circuit, lub możemy po prostu myśleć o U abstrakcyjnie
jako o operacji unitarnej,
a jako wejście U przyjmuje albo stan Psi, albo stan Phi,
razem z paczką zainicjalizowanych qubitów, o których możesz myśleć jako o qubitach roboczych, które jakoś wspomagają ten
proces rozróżniania.
Po zastosowaniu U, górny qubit jest mierzony za pomocą pomiaru standardowej bazy i tutaj jest część o doskonałym
rozróżnianiu.
Jeśli stanem wejściowym był Psi, to pomiar musi
dać wynik zero ze 100% prawdopodobieństwem, a jeśli
stanem wejściowym był Phi,
to pomiar musi
dać wynik jeden, znowu ze 100% szansą.
Nie jest ważne, jakie są
stany tych innych qubitów po zastosowaniu U.
Liczy się tylko ten jeden bit, który dostajemy z pomiaru, bo to ten bit mówi nam, który z dwóch stanów był naszym punktem startowym.
Dla niektórych wyborów stanów Psi i Phi będzie możliwe przeprowadzenie doskonałego rozróżnienia
takiego jak tutaj, a dla innych nie.
I co zaobserwujemy: jeśli
jest to możliwe, to Psi i Phi muszą być stanami ortogonalnymi,
a to oznacza, że jeśli Phi i
Psi nie są ortogonalne, nie możesz ich doskonale rozróżnić.
Zobaczmy więc, dlaczego doskonałe rozróżnienie implikuje ortogonalność.
Zacznijmy od zapisania dwóch równań wyrażających to, co wyrażają te
dwa diagramy.
Jeśli pomyślimy o stanie kwantowym, który dostajemy po zastosowaniu U do
paczki zainicjalizowanych qubitów razem ze stanem Psi,
widzimy, że musi
mieć tę formę tutaj, gdzie Pi zero to jakiś wektor stanu kwantowego reprezentujący stan
wszystkich tych qubitów
oprócz górnego. Nie mamy żadnej informacji
o tym stanie kwantowym Pi zero — może być czymkolwiek —
ale wiemy, że cały
stan musi wyglądać tak, bo to jedyny
sposób, żeby pomiar był gwarantowany dawać
wynik zero ze 100%.
I mamy analogiczne
równanie dla drugiego przypadku.
Tym razem górny qubit
musi być w stanie jeden, i podobnie do Pi zero, stan
Pi jeden może być czymkolwiek.
I poza tym, że nie mamy
informacji o Pi jeden, nie wiemy też nic
o związku między Pi zero i Pi jeden.
O ile wiemy, to po prostu dwa
dowolne stany kwantowe.
WEBVTT
Co możemy zrobić następnie, to
pomnożyć obie strony tych równań
po obu stronach przez U dagger, czyli sprzężenie hermitowskie U.
I jeśli to zrobimy, otrzymamy dwa równania,
które widzisz tutaj.
Używamy faktu, że U dagger razy U to macierz identyczności.
Dlatego właśnie nie widzimy U ani U dagger po lewej stronie żadnego z równań.
I teraz możemy rozważyć iloczyn skalarny między Psi i Phi.
Jest on taki sam jak iloczyn
skalarny Psi i Phi pomnożony przez iloczyn
skalarny stanu L zero z samym sobą,
bo iloczyn skalarny
dowolnego stanu z samym sobą wynosi jeden — i dotyczy to stanu L zero.
I teraz patrząc na nasze dwa równania widzimy, że to wyrażenie tutaj jest równe iloczynowi skalarnemu wektorów
reprezentowanych przez te dwa równania. W szczególności jest to iloczyn skalarny między lewymi stronami
tych równań.
Więc możemy równie dobrze
wyrazić ten iloczyn skalarny jako iloczyn skalarny wektorów reprezentowanych przez prawe strony tych równań,
bo lewa strona jest
równa prawej stronie dla obu równań.
Dostajemy więc to wyrażenie tutaj, które jest iloczynem skalarnym
dwóch prawych stron równań — równoważnie
jest to sprzężenie hermitowskie pierwszego pomnożone przez drugie.
U razy U dagger jest równe
macierzy identyczności, bo U jest unitarne, więc znika.
I możemy uprościć tylko trochę, żeby dostać iloczyn
tych iloczynów skalarnych.
Pamiętaj, że nie wiemy nic o związku
między Pi zero i Pi jeden, więc nie wiemy, czym jest
ich iloczyn skalarny.
To jest dla nas zagadką. Ale cokolwiek nim jest, mnożymy go przez iloczyn skalarny Ket 0 i Ket jeden, który wynosi zero.
Więc końcowy wynik jest taki, że
otrzymujemy wartość zero — ale to właśnie chcieliśmy pokazać: iloczyn skalarny między
Psi i Phi jest równy zero.
Więc te dwa stany są ortogonalne.
Więc nie próbuj
doskonale rozróżniać dwóch nieortogonalnych stanów kwantowych — po prostu nie możesz tego zrobić.
Istnieje twierdzenie odwrotne do
tego, które właśnie udowodniliśmy — a mianowicie, że ortogonalne stany kwantowe zawsze można doskonale rozróżnić,
i nie jest to zbyt trudne do
zobaczenia, jeśli skorzystamy z faktu, który wspomniałem wcześniej w lekcji.
Konkretnie jeśli Psi i
Phi są stanami ortogonalnymi, to jedną rzeczą, którą możemy zrobić, jest wybór dowolnej macierzy unitarnej U,
której pierwsze dwie kolumny
to te dwa stany.
Wiemy, że zawsze
jest to możliwe i nie ma znaczenia
dla celów tego zadania, jak dokładnie ta macierz unitarna jest wybrana.
Ważne jest tylko to, że to są pierwsze dwie kolumny.
Nie potrzebujemy żadnych dodatkowych qubitów. Jeśli po prostu zastosujemy U do
dwóch możliwych stanów, uzyskamy te
dwa możliwe wyniki.
I jeśli zmierzymy najbardziej górny qubit — pamiętaj, że to jest najbardziej prawy qubit — uzyskamy zero lub jeden,
zależnie od tego, od którego stanu zaczęliśmy.
Alternatywnie możemy rozważyć
pomiar rzutowy z wynikami zero i jeden
zdefiniowany tak jak widzisz tutaj.
W tym przypadku pomiar
faktycznie zależy tylko od Psi.
Ten pomiar doskonale
rozróżnia Psi od dowolnego stanu ortogonalnego do Psi.
Jeśli mierzymy Psi za pomocą tego pomiaru rzutowego, uzyskamy wynik
zero z prawdopodobieństwem jeden, jak pokazują te równania.
I dla dowolnego stanu Phi
ortogonalnego do Psi uzyskamy wynik
jeden z prawdopodobieństwem jeden.
Nie będę przechodzić przez
szczegóły tych obliczeń, ale jeśli chcesz, zachęcam cię do samodzielnego ich prześledzenia.
I to jest koniec lekcji trzeciej. Omówiliśmy dużo
materiału w tej lekcji, w tym quantum circuits,
iloczyny skalarne i ortonormalność, rzuty i pomiary rzutowe, fakt, że globalne fazy nie mają znaczenia,
twierdzenie o nieklonowaniu oraz fakt, że nieortogonalnych stanów nie można doskonale rozróżnić, podczas gdy ortogonalne można.
Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie na
czwartej lekcji wkrótce, która jest ostatnią lekcją w
pierwszej jednostce serii.
W czwartej lekcji porozmawiamy o trzech
bardzo ważnych przykładach: teleportacji, supergęstym kodowaniu,
oraz nierówności CHSH lub grze CHSH, jak jest czasem opisywana.
Do zobaczenia wkrótce,